bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver notre grand témoin vous
le reconnaissez ce soir c'est Fran
Olivier gisber bonsoir merci d'être
d'être avec nous on va passer l'heure en
direct et on a dévorer le 3e tome de
votre histoire intime de la 5e
République qui cartonne déjà d'ailleurs
en librairie tragédie française chez
galima où l'histoire de ces SEP
démolisseurs qui ont conduit la France
dans le mur selon vous pas que cinq
présidents deux premiers ministres
responsables de la déliquissence du pays
les mots sont forts c'est féroces comme
toujours un poil RAC quand même on en
parlera mais pas des clinistes vous nous
direz pourquoi tout n'est pas foutu tout
à l'heure notre grand débat ce soir vous
reprendrez bien un peu de glyphosate la
décision est tombée ce matin faute
d'accord des 27 la Commission européenne
renouvelle l'autorisation de cet
herbicide controversé pour 10 ans
supplémentaires a-t-elle cédé au lobby
quelles conséquences sur la santé nous
en débattons dans un instant avec nos
invités enfin nos affranchis ce soir le
billet politique de yel Goose le billet
philo de Nathan de vert et puis Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
signé Marco Pomier voilà pour le menu ce
soir on y va France France Olivier gbert
1 heure en direct ça commence
maintenant
[Musique]
quelle semble loin la promesse
présidentielle de sortir du glyphosate
en 3 ans la Commission européenne a donc
autorisé l'utilisation de cette
herbicide pour 10 ans de plus erreur
monumentale pour les écologistes ou SAG
décision pour nos agriculteurs bonsoir
Valérie eyet bienvenue à vous vous êtes
député européenne député renew c'est le
groupe Renaissance le groupe Macron
à Bruxelles vous débattez ce soir avec
Eva SAS bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes député écologiste de Paris bonsoir
Jean-Baptiste Mar Mar Morau pardon je
suis sûr qu'on vous l'avez déjà fait
Jean-Baptiste Morau consultant
indépendant agriculteur en reconversion
et ancien député bien connu de ce
plateau député la République en marche
de la Creuse enfin bonsoir Emmanuel
Vanam bienvenue à vous vous êtes paysan
en agriculture biologique sur le plateau
de sa dans les sones et membre de la
confédération paysane inutile de
préciser Fran Olivier gisberg que vous
pouvez intervenir quand vous souhaitez
dans ce débat on va commencer par
planter le décor comment la Commission
européenne est parvenue à cette décision
c'est avec Stéphan blackakovski dans son
chrono tout de
suite bonsoir mon cher Stéphane je me
retourne comme chaque soir pour vous
accueillir bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors cette décision donc l'Union
européenne a décidé d'autoriser le
glyphosate pour 10 ans de plus il va y
avoir un débat ça sera très an mais
avant d'en arriver là peut-être qu'on
peut essayer de comprendre comment la
décision a été prise alors évidemment
avant de proposer de prolonger l'usage
du gyptosat la Commission a commandé une
enquête scientifique à l'agence
sanitaire européenne voyez c'est FFSA
c'est un acronyme anglais donc un
rapport rendit en juillet 4 expé ont
participé ça repose sur 2400 études le
rapport fait au total 180000 pages donc
je ne sais pas qui a lu les 180000 pages
ah je crois que Baptiste Mor est arrivé
la 170000 ouais c'est ça j'ai fini sur
les 10000 derniers je vous montre malgré
tout le titre donc du rapport qui dit
d'une part que il n'y a pas de risque à
utiliser le glyphosate mais cependant
qui reconnaît aussi qu'il y a un certain
manque dans les données donc le résultat
c'est que Pascal campfin qui est un
député européen renew donc Renaissance
mais qui est surtout le président de la
commission Environnement Parlement
européen et bien il estime que la
Commission aurait dû être beaucoup plus
prudente avant de renouveler l'autor on
l'écoute c'est le problème de la
décision de la commission qui n'a pas
tenu compte de la complexité de l'avis
de l'fsa elle s'est contenté de prendre
le premier message elle a ignoré tout le
reste et ce n'est pas équilibré ce n'est
donc pas
acceptable alors cela dit les
parlementaires montrent du Do la
commission mais la Commission ne prend
pas la décision toute seule la décision
est soumis au vote des États-membres
donc le vote a eu lieu ce matin voici le
résultat 17 état se sont prononcés pour
donc la prolongation de l'utilisation du
glyphosate trois étent contre le
Luxembourg la Croatie et l'Autriche he
pas des grandes puissance agricole et
SEP se sont abstenus donc simplement
c'est un vote la majorité qualifiée donc
pour avoir la majorité il faut qu'au
moins qu 15 États soient pour donc c'est
bon il y avait 17 États mais il faut que
la population de ces 15 États
corresponde à au moins 65 % de la
population européenne et là ça ne marche
pas parce que parmi les SEP pays qui se
sont abstenus il y a les pays les plus
peuplés de l'Union européenne
l'Allemagne l'Italie et la France donc
résultat comme les États-membres n'ont
pas réussi à se mettre d'accord bien
c'est la Commission qui a pris les
décision de renouveler l'autorisation
alors évidemment côté français on peut
s'étonner qu'on se soit simplement
abstenu puisque souvenez-vous en 2017 le
président Macron voulait être un
pionnier de la lutte contre le
glyphosate il avait dit d'ici 3 ans ça
serait ça sera interdit mais le
président peut se tromper en tout cas il
a reconnu son erreur en disant ah non là
sur ce coupl-à c'est une erreur parce
que on peut pas interdire le le
glyphosate pardon aux agriculteurs si on
leur offre pas un produit aussi efficace
en échange bon alors dans ce cas-là
évidemment en France on dit OUI l'usage
du rglyphosate a quand même été beaucoup
restreint euh même le ministre dit que
il a diminué de 30 % ces dernières
années sauf que pour ceux qui veulent
une interdiction totale et bien la
France n'aurait pas dû s'abstenir elle
aurait dû voter contre le renouvellement
de l'autorisation on écoute h r trouver
etfi le gouvernement a été lâche
hypocrite et cynique la première chose à
faire c'était de voter contre par une
une énorme lâcheté et hypocrisie il a il
s'est abstenu lâche hypocrite B je sais
pas mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que le gouvernement est quand même
très embarrassé parce que sur le
principe le gouvernement aimerait
pouvoir interdire le glyphosate
reprendre ce flambeau du pionnier contre
la de la lutte contre les pesticides
sauf que si on est les seuls à interdire
le glyphosate pendant que d'autres pays
continuent à l'utiliser et ben ça va
poser de nouveaux problèmes sur en tout
cas ce que disait Olivier verérrand sur
France Info c'était il y a un mois la
France considère qu'il n'y a pas
vocation à à reconduire pendant 10 ans
en faisant comme s'il y avait pas des
alternatives qui se développent
l'utilisation de glyphosate mais encore
faut-il qu'il y ait des alternatives
partout parce que si vous laissez les
agriculteurs sans alternatives vous me
réinviterez pour me dire la France n'est
plus capable de fournir des fruits et
légumes et on achète des produits au
Maghreb remplis de glyphosate comment
est-ce que vous expliquez ça bon ben
voilà vous avez les éléments pour suivre
le débat qui va commencer un débat où
tout le monde ne sera pas d'accord mais
à quoi ça sert d'être d'accord dans un
débat Françis et ben justement merci
beaucoup on va on va y aller dans ce
débat merci Stéphane Valérie Eyer c'est
vrai que la France en 2017 voter contre
l'utilisation du glyphosade au niveau
européen 5 ans plus tard elle s'abstient
est-ce que vous pensez que les les
Français peuvent comprendre cette volte
faceas les Français comprennent la
situation aussi du droit en France
aujourd'hui euh depuis 2018 on a une
ligne qui est absolument claire qui est
en faveur de la sortie progressive du
glyphosate euh dès lors que c'est-à-dire
interdiction du glyphosate dès lors
qu'il existe une alternative naturelle
ou mécanique et cette abstention
aujourd'hui de la France par rapport à
la proposition de la Commission elle est
évidemment dans l'esprit de la position
de la France à la fois elle ne voulait
pas évidemment voter en faveur de la
proposition de la Commission
c'est-à-dire pas de réouverture sans
conditions pas de réautorisation sans
mais voter contre clairement ce serait
quoi nous tirer une balle dans le pied
par rapport à nos voisins européens
s'abstenir c'est aussi envoyer le
message à la Commission et aux
partenaires européens que la France est
ouverte à la discussion et que
d'ailleurs elle souhaitait que que
l'Union européenne s'inspire du modèle
français pour faire une nouvelle
proposition la commission elle aurait pu
mettre une nouvelle proposition sur la
table regr la décision d'aujourd'hui de
la commion je regrette totalement la
décision de la Commission je pense que
c'est une erreur de forme et de fond de
forme elle a pris cette décision elle
était en droit de le faire dès lors
qu'il n'y avait pas de majorité
qualifiée qui se dessinait au conseil
c'est vrai mais elle a revisiter un peu
les traités parce que c'est c'est pas
très démocratique les commissaires sont
pas élus les États sont S
le Parlement est élu c'est la procédure
oui c'est la procédure donc voilà sur
cette question là la commission pouvait
prendre la décision seule dè l'ORS qu'il
n'y avait pas de majorité qualifiée au
Conseil elle l'a fait sans avoir le
soutien des trois principales puissances
agricoles pas le soutien de la France
pas le soutien de l'Allemagne pas le
soutien de l'Italie donc voilà pour la
forme c'est regrettable et puis pour le
fond elle avait une occasion
extraordinaire de faire une proposition
qui permettent à la fois de protéger
l'environnement et de protéger nos
agriculteurs pour leur garantir une
concurrence équitable et loyal partout
en Europe en s'inspirant du modèle
français elle a choisi de laisser les
états décider chacun donc on aura 27
modèles différents ou donc si on
s'arrête votre position c'est tous
ensemble mais pas séparément pour
résumer evasas pour vous c'est une faute
cette décision de la Commission
européenne oui c'est évidemment une
faute mais je j'admire l'habileté avec
laquelle ma collègue député européenne
essae de se sortir de ce mauvais pas
parce qu'il y a quand même une une
intense contradiction entre les discours
qui ont été tenus en France avec un
Emmanuel Macron qui en 2017 dit on
sortira au plus tard dans 3 ans du
glyphosate qui en 2021 dit ah mais j'ai
fait une erreur il faut le faire au
niveau européen et qui là en 2023 la
France s'abstient sur cette décision
c'est incompréhensible c'est des
revirements et on a vraiment
l'impression que vous capitulez devant
les lobbyes et que comme chaque fois
dans en matière d'écologie en fait au
final il y a des discours mais il n'y a
jamais d'actes derrière donc moi je
pense que c'est une faute de la
commission mais c'est aussi une faute de
la France de ne pas avoir voté contre il
fallait être clair dans notre position
pour faire progresser ce sujet parce que
là on a encore malheureusement ce
glyphosate qui a des conséquences sur la
santé humaine maintenant avéré vir alors
Jean-Baptiste Morau est-ce qu'il y a pas
un peu d'hypocrisie quand même dans
cette abstention française d'un côté la
France s'impose des contraintes plus
fortes dans l'utilisation du glyphosate
par rapport à à l'Europe mais de l'autre
elle s'abstient au niveau européen alors
je suis le seul ici qui était député en
2010 à l'époque du tweet du président de
la République je peux vous dire que ce
tweet il a donné lieu à quelques
échanges un peu salés entre moi et lui
mais aussi entre lui et d'autres
personne personne celui de la promesse
d'e interdictionou d'une interdiction
parce que parce que à l'époque j'étais
rapporteur de la loi égalim et un
certain nombre de députés ont voulu
l'inscrire cette interdiction dans dans
la loi et je me'y suis opposé en tant
que rapporteur Stéphane traver qui à
l'époque était ministre s est opposé en
tant que ministre aussi parce que on on
avait besoin de on n'est pas des soldats
d'une d'un dogme d'une croyance enfin
moi je l'étais pas en en tant que député
et donc je voulais avoir tous les
éléments avant de décider et pas
uniquement faire une interdiction sur
pour le prix d'un symbole alors qu'on
mettait un certain nombre de nos
agriculteurs et un certain nombre de
pratiques agricoles actuelles dans de
grandes difficultés donc on a enclenché
une mission j'ai été rpport cor
rapporteur avec Jean-Luc fugit à
l'époque de cette mission parlementaire
qui a travaillé pendant 2 ans qui a
auditionné des chercheurs alors travail
moins comple que celui qui a pu faire
l'fsa parce que l'fsa s'est allé sur
beaucoup plus de temp et beaucoup plus
l'agence européne de santé et de
l'alimentation qui a fait un rapport que
j'ai lu en grand partie pas de totalité
pas les 180000 pages je le concède mais
en grande partie euh mais nous on avait
aussi fait un rapport sur les la base
duquel sont tombés des interdictions
d'usage du glyphosate en 2018 avec tous
les usages justement où il y avait des
alternatives comme l'a dit Valée tout à
l'heure ou qui qui qui était interdit
mais on a un certain nombre d'usage
aujourd'hui qui où il y a pas
d'alternative pour les agriculteurs on a
déjà une agriculture qui ne produit plus
suffisamment pour nourrir les Français
faut le savoir on importe un certain
nombre de produits agricoles que soit de
la viande soit des fruits et légumes que
soit un certain nombre de production la
diminuer encore la nos productions
agricoles c'est ouvrir encore plus la
porte aux importations qu quelles
contraintes vont vont s'appliquer en
fait c'est ça qu'on narrive pas à
comprendre il y a d'un côté des
contraintes qui qui pèsent au niveau
européen parce que c'est pas une une
reconduction une prolongation sur 10 ans
sans quelques contrainte mais elles sont
beaucoup moins fortes que celles que
s'impose la France alors nos
agriculteurs eux qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
faire c'est la loi française qui
effectivement la deuxème proposition de
la Commission était plus plus dure que
la première puisque ils ont interdit
NOTAM
l'utilisation de glyphosate dans la
dciication c'estàd pour faire sécher les
plantes sur pied ça donc les
agriculteurs français ou les
viticulteurs français sont moins
contraint que les espagnol plus plus
contraint que les espagol plus contraint
que les Espagnols effectivement les
Allemands bien sûr parce que l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne le Luxembourg ont voté
contre Luxembourg a voté contre la
résolution sauf que chez eux ils l'ont
pas interdit au jour d'aujourd'hui
Emmanuel VAM la Confédération paysane je
l'ai lu aujourd'hui dénonce une erreur
monumentale de la commission oui moi je
dis quelle belle marche arrière
franchement vraiment
euh c'est atterrant moi je suis
agriculteur je travaille sans glyphosate
on peut travailler avec enfin on peut
travailler sans ces produits j'entends
ce que vous dites et je comprends pas
sans rentrer dans le débat technique euh
pour les frites et légumes et pour la
viticulture je vois pas où où intervient
le glyphosate euh pour l'alimentation
animale je vois mal pour les céréales la
partie céréalière je vois bien mais les
alternatives sans rentrer dans le débat
elles existent très c'est super facile
en fait oui sauf qu'on condamne un
certain nombre de pratiques comme
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
qui doit être l'avenir de de la culture
pour moi et qui n'est pas possible à à
faire sans glyphosate demain elle est
elle est aujourd'hui pas majoritaire
mais c'est à mon avis quelque chose qui
permet de piéger le carbone d'éviter
l'érosion et je suis policulteur éleveur
moi non plus j'utilise pas de glyphosat
donc c'est pas je défends pas mon inérêt
c'est quoi le pourcentage de
d'agriculteur qu'utilise qu'utilise
aujourd'hui qui font qui font de
l'agriculture de conservation
aujourd'hui trop faible beaucoup trop
faible par rapport à ce qu'il devrait
être ce sont pas ceuxl qu'on entend on
est bien d'accord on parle pas de ceuxa
on parle de tous les autres oui mais
l'interdiction c'est pour tout le monde
mais d'accord mais ENF je dire
j'entendais ça tout à l'heure en venant
dans l'auto je je dire voilà
l'agriculture de conservation des de
conservation des sols nous en bio on
essa aussi c'est encore plus comp
peut-être pour pour bien comprendre
parce que c'est un débat technique et
puis tout le monde n'a pas la chance
d'avoir une exploitation comme vous les
les interdictions elles pèsent partout
où il existe une alternative non
chimique c'est ça aujourd'hui en France
c'est interdit pour l'pendage
c'est-à-dire la dispersion dans des
champs quand ils sont près des habit
5 10 m c'est ça il y a d'autres
interdictions en France dans les dans
les vignes dans les rond de viges dans
les arbres fruitiers c'est interdit je
sais pas où c'est interdit et où c'est
autorisé mais oui ça doit être ça c'est
les bordures de champs les bordures de
maison et cetera et cetera enfin voilà
mais enfin je veux dire nous on
travaille moi je suis agriculteur
céréalier donc je fais partie du groupe
des agriculteurs qu'on qui qui qui qui
qui souhait que le pardon je suis dans
le même groupe que les autres
agriculteurs céréaliers qui aimeraient
continuer d'utiliser du glyphosate et du
coup qu'ils vont avoir le droit de
l'utiliser pendant 10 ans alors que nous
on l'utilise pas et moi ça fait plus de
15 ans que je que je suis en agriculture
biologique et ça va très bien et ben
justement on va regarder ça très
concrètement sur juste parce que quand
je dis une belle marche arrière
c'est-à-dire que on a un gouvernement
qui nous prône l'écologie sans arrêt
mais qui fait marche arrière sur à peu
près tout même sur le soutien à
l'agriculture biologique donc c'est
enfin je veux dire il y a un moment il y
a un moment on va dans quel sens c'est
quoi la direction alors justement pour
se figurer les choses dans sur le
terrain et puis euh dans les
exploitations regardez ce ce sujet
pourquoi certains arrivent à se passer
du glyphosate et d'autres non reportage
dans la Vienne Augustin Arnal Arianne
mauisson pour France
Télévision à l'approche des semis
Sébastien berger contrôle l'état de son
champ il y a quelques jours il a
désherbé sa parcelle en pulvérisant un
produit chimique puissant du
glyphosate sous 15 jours 3 3 semaines on
va commencer à avoir une plante qui
dessèche et on va obtenir ce genre de
chose une plante qui est qui a plus de
chlorophyle depuis 3 ans cet agriculteur
a divisé par de sa consommation de
glyphosate grâce au désherbage mécanique
un complément efficace mais impossible
selon lui de se priver totalement du
puissant herbicide on a des plantes
résistantes qui sont plantes invasives
et ces plantes là à part la molécule du
glyphosate pour la réguler aujourd'hui
j'ai rien d'autre Sébastien berger
répand 1 lre d'herbicide par hectare de
culture donc là j'ai du mon côté droit
la fameuse molécule du glyphosate malgré
la dangerosité du produit il continue
d'utiliser la molécule pour assurer ses
récoltes faute d'alternative efficace
c'est pas parce qu'on a employer une
mollécule qu'on l'emploiera demain et la
preuve en est c'est que nos pratiques
vont ver des pratiques plus vertueuses
et j'en prends pour exemple chez moi
j'en consommais 800 l il y a quelques
années aujourd'hui j'en suis rendu à 400
sur ma ferme et et demain ça ira
peut-être encore en diminuant à quelques
kilomètres de là pendant 12 ans Damien
savoyant a lui aussi pulvérisé du
glyphosate sur séchamp en 2016 il a
renoncé aux produits chimiques et s'est
converti à l'agriculture biologique à
présent il ne compte que sur des outil
mécaniques pour déerbés les repousses de
tournesol sont arraché et les quelques
mauvaises herbes qui qui sont présente
aussi dans le champ qui sont également
arraché un procédé plus long et plus
coûteux qui l'amorti avec un prix de
vente plus élevé de sa production
l'absence de recours au glyphosate est
avant tout un moyen pour lui de protéger
l'environnement aujourd'hui il y a des
études qui le montrent on sait que ça
coûte moins cher d'aider l'agriculteur
que de dépolluer l'eau le glyphosate
demeure encore l'herbicide le plus
utilisé en France en 2021 près de 7800
tonnes ont été vendu sur le territoire
national un chiffre en légère baisse ces
dernières
années alors Valé on le voit bien dans
le reportage on peut s'en passer on peut
restreindre l'utilisation du du
glyphosate le frein c'est toujours le
même il est économique puisque faire du
bio s glyphosate ça coûte plus cher donc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire il y a
l'enjeu de la productivité et puis par
ailleurs passer toutes les on on peut
pas imaginer de passer toutes nos
exploitations agricoles en France dans
le bio puisque il faut que les
consommateurs soient au rendez-vous on
sur en période d'inflation le bio
s'effondre effectivement donc il faut
continuer d'accompagner effectivement la
agriculture biologique et accompagner au
mieux toujours
l'agriculture traditionnelle raisonnée
je dirais conventionnelle pardonne-moi
euh et et vraiment la position de la
France quand j'entends parler de voltef
de marche en arrière effectivement c'est
pragmatisme de la part du président de
la République lui-même l'a reconnu en
2018 et l'abstention parce que je
voudrais réagir à ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure j'aiai pas réagi sur le
coup pardonnez-moi mais l'abstention de
la France si la France avait voté contre
ça n'aurait rien
changé à la décision
il aurait il auraitu les TR pays on a TR
pays qui ont voté contre on en a se qui
se sont abstenus si les 7 qui s'étaient
abstenu avaient voté contre on nurait
pas eu la majorité qualifi donc en fait
vous anticipiez le rapport de force et
l'abstention permet au
fond d'éviter des des des difficultés de
concurrence avec demander à la
Commission de revoir sa copie pour
soutenir l'ensemble des agricultures et
accompagner les agriculteurs dans cette
sortie progressive du glyphosat ou alors
la question maintenant c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on sait euh de façon claire euh et et
et vérifier sur sur les conséquences sur
la santé parce que là on a on assiste à
des bataille c'est tou la même histoire
reste toujours oui oui c'est c'est une
histoire très ancienne hein 2015 il y a
longtemps le le rapport de l'omspp tout
à fait il y a très longtemps et rien
avancé depuis c'est-à-dire que est-ce
que c'est vraiment si dangereux moi je
j'aurais tendance à être contre les
insecticides et les herbicides mais
c'est vrai que moi je comprends tout à
fait la position je suis pas suspect
d'être macroniste
mais
vraiment non mais franchement dans cette
affaire il faut y aller quand même
modérément parce que il y a un monde
agricole qui est quand même en danger en
France on était le jardin de l'Europe on
est de moins en moins ce jardin vous le
savez très bien nous consommons de plus
en plus de fruits et légumes qui
viennent de nos voisins il faut quand
même donc si on se sépare du glyphosate
et si on arrête le glyphosate il faut le
faire prog ement c'est clair c'est sans
doute dangereux mais ce n'est pas
absolument avéré et de toute façon il
faut faire principe de précaution mais
est-ce qu'il faut arrêter tout d'un coup
c'est quand même compliqué pourure
française il y a beaucoup y a quand même
il y a tout un passé il y a des
traditions et c'est quand même une
grande partie de la France et on a
l'impression que allez hop on fait allez
on arrête c'est TER mais ça peut pas ch
la question de la santé publique et la
question des alternatives on va les
prendre dans l'ordre sur la santé
publique c'est vrai qu'on a cette grande
étude de l'OMS donc organisation
internationale et puis maintenant CIT
giga étude si j'ose dire de l'fsa donc
ça c'est l'Agence européenne de de santé
et et d'alimentation qui qui disent deux
choses différentes cancérogène d'un côté
et pas assez de données mais a priori
pas de risque sur les les fameux cancers
qu' qu'on a pu rencontrer avec des
actions en justice en cas d'utilisation
du du glyphosate est-ce que pour vous
certaines de ces agences sont
contestable ou pas bah en l'occurrence
déjà en 2015 que vous l'avez dit ça a
été reconnu quand c'est rgine problme
par l'OMS il a ensuite eu l'étude de
l'incerme en 2021 qui a aussi montré
qu'il y avait des effets neurotoxiques
de perturbateur endocriniens récemment
il y a une décision du fond
d'indemnisation des victimes qui a
indemnisé un jeune garçon parce que il
est handicapé parce que sa euh sa mère a
été en contact avec le glyphosate
pendant la grossesse donc il y a une
reconnaissance du caractère dangereux du
glyphosate aux États-Unis il y a
énormément alors ça varie parce qu'il y
a eu des très très gros procès avec des
condamnations à des à mon Santo Bager
plusieurs millions d'euros on pense à ce
jardinier mais très récemment c'est
l'inverse faute de preuve acquitement
donc c'est compliqué qu'est-ce que vous
répondez sur la dangerosité non mais la
dangerosité c'est pas parce qu'une
hnerie répété des milliers de fois la
longueur de plateau télé que ça devient
une vérité l'agence de l'fsa c'est 2000
étude effectivement il y en a deux ou
trois qui disent le contraire il y a
2000 qui disent la vérité enfin moi je
suis un scientifique la science c'est
pas de la croyance la science le fait
scientifique c'est en principe quand
vous avez 2000 études qui disent la même
chose elles ont plus de chance d'être
juste que les trois qui disent le
contraire honnêtement mais les données
prises en cause par les parce qu'on peut
lire ici ou là que ces données elles
sont fournies par les fabricants eumême
par les la science est dans notre côté
question moi je dis quand la science est
de notre côté c'est bon ça ça va c'est
de la science quand elle est pas de
notre côté c'est les lobby enfin je veux
dire cette vision binaire de la société
finit par décrédibiliser la science la
science n'est pas une croyance la
science c'est la science moi je suis un
bête ingénieur agronome j'ai j'ai j'ai
étudié pendant mes études tout un tas de
choses scientifiques qui sont avérés
alors la science peut évoluer et
effectivement il peut y avoir des des
mises à jour de données mais sur un
aussi grand nombre de données pareil
quand quand on parle de la santé des
agriculteurs bien sûr qu'il faut
protéger les agriculteurs et bien sûr
que les agriculteurs n'utilisent pas les
produits phyosanitaires par plaisir mais
parce qu'ils doivent les utiliser pour
assurer un rendement minimum pour
pouvoir vivre de leur métier ce qui est
pas ce qui est pas une injure mais quand
on regarde la la l'étude agricane qui
résume tout qui prend en compte des
milliers de données d'agriculteurs de la
MSA depuis les années 80 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et qui montrre que les
agriculteurs sont moins sujets au cancer
et à différentes pathologies que la
moyenne de la population donc je veux
dire on peut dire que les produits
phytosanitires sont dangereux pour les
agriculteurs sauf que dans les faits
l'étude agricane prouve exactement le
contraire alors Valéri sur la question
des risques sur la santé humaine vous
quellez qu'est-ce qu'on doit dire
conviction vérité c'est pas évident hein
c'est une étude des analation
scientifiqu très sérieuses qui ont été
produites par l'fsa et je crois en la
science et je fais confiance à l'analyse
de l'EFSA ce qu'elle dit c'est que a
priorie il y a pas de danger pour la
santé humaine mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
des zones grises sur la question de la
biodiversité et et et quelques éléments
sur le Biotop humain qui pose quelques
questions d'où nos interrogations aussi
encore qui persistent sur la question un
manque de données c'est c'est c'est
cette zone grise aussi là qui explique
notre position à savoir soyons quand
même les études sont intéress est
rassurante sur la santé humaine mais il
y a quand même des zonres grises qui
existent pour la protection de
l'environnement et le et le biotope
humain donc soyons vigilant et d'où
cette position maintenue de sortie
progressive du glyphosate où en sont la
les recherches en matière d'alternative
au glyphosate on a l'INE Rae dont on est
très fier en France Emmanuel Van Dam
est-ce qu'il existe des alternatives
précises pour les agriculteurs V pas
répondre à votre question parce que je
suis pas je suis pas chimiste je suis
pas chercheur et vous me posez cette
question à moi quelqu'un R vous cette
question à moi qui suis agriculteur
biologique mais juste je vrais revenir
de quoi on parle on parle juste d'
d'interdire un pesticide parmi tempant
d'autres d'accord et et si on prend un
petit peu de hauteur et avec ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans notre dans notre
monde avec ce qu'on sait sur tous les
pesticides en règle générale on a envie
de quoi on a envie de les arrêter les
uns après les autres mais tous les 10
ans parce que faut y aller doucement ou
où on prend une vraie décision et on
montre l'exemple à la Commission en
disant non plutôt que de dire voà je
sais pas je vais pas le faire parce que
j'ai peur des lobis j'ai peur de la
FNSEA et j'ai peur de tout le monde donc
enfin voilà de quoi on parle quoi DEP 20
un grand nombre de produit phyosanitair
ce qui nous met en distorsion de
concurrence par rapport à la plart des
pays du monde exemple oui bien sûr alors
typiquement on laave oui on a interdit
la
carotte m étrangèr qu'est-ce qui est le
plus important sur la betterave sucrière
puisque on a interdit ce fameux
insecticide qu'est-ce qui est le plus
important c'est d'avoir du sucre et de
faire vivre une filière de 45000
personnes ou c'est d'avoir des abeilles
dans les champs c'est quoi le plus
important vous avez raison on est
d'accord on est forcément d'accord
là-dessus en même temps est-ce qu'il
faut pas prendre un peu de temps voilà
on voit très bien ce quià interdit un
paquet de molécules toutes les plus
dangereuses ont été interdites au fur à
mesure depuis 20 ans on prend les
décisions elles sont prises sur avis de
l'anest par les différents ministres de
l'Agriculture et ça ça demande pas à
cette majorité mais toutes les
précédentes l'ont fait aussi mais le
temps de la recherche c'est long alors
quelles sont les alternatives
aujourd'hui est-ce oui mais le temp
l'agriculture c'est long aussi
l'agriculture ça ça on transforme pas un
modèle agricole en claquant des doigts
et on transforme pas un modèle agricole
parce qu'on le décrète je veux dire on
peut passer à 100 % en bio demain s'il y
a personne pour l'acheter on va faire
les mêmes su on a l'impression que c'est
devenu un totem le gphosat pour en finir
avec la on va faire les mêmes bêtises
qu'on a fait avec l'agriculture
conventionnelle on produit on sait pas
si s'il y a un consommateur au bout pour
l'acheter et ben c'est ce qu'on a fait
avec le bio depuis des années à moment
moi je suis favorable à l'agriculture
biologique et son développement à
condition qu'on ait un marché au bout et
qu'on mette pas des agriculteurs dans la
panade parce qu'on les emmène vers un
modèle agricole qui n'a aucune
rentabilité économiqueerer ça c'est
important là c'est l'agriculteur qui
parle qui parle il a totalement raison
il y a de la place pour tous les modèles
en France et en Europe il faut
accompagner le développement des
agricultures biologiques il faut que les
consommateurs soient prêts à l'acheter
on a vu la chute aussi du niveau de
consommation et il faut aussi
accompagner l'agriculteur conventionnel
je voudrais dire en complément de ce
quité dit la semaine prochaine au
Parlement européen on vote sur un texte
pour fixer des objectifs de réduction
aussi des produits phytosanitaire et
comme l'a dit Jean-Baptiste il y a pas
un agriculteur qui a du plaisir à
utiliser des produits phytosanitaires
donc là encore la ligne ne jamais opposé
agriculture et écologie ne jamais je
crois opposer les modèles et sortir
progressivement le évidemment dans la
mesure du possible d'un point de vue
technique et d'un point de vue
économique réduire progressivement le
l'utilisation des des des produit
phytosanitaires progressivité euh il
aller pas pas à pas accompagnement aussi
des des agriculs ur pour ne pas aussi
perdre totalement nos marchés c'est
important oui mais c'est pas ce que ce à
quoi je d'abord il y a quelque chose que
je comprends pas dans V discours c'est
que soit vous pensez que c'est dangereux
et alors il faut l'interdire soit vous
pensez que c'est pas dangereux et alors
à ce moment-là il c'est pas la peine de
faire cette politique de restriction et
et de recherche d'alternative je trouve
qu'il y a une espèce d'incohérence dans
votre discours
nousom nous somes clair nous pensons que
c'est dangereux ça a été avéré vous
parliez de l'étude de l'fsa mais il a
été dit à plus plusieurs reprises que
elle prenait en compte que certaines
études scientifiques pas et pas du tout
l'intégralité comme le fait d'ailleurs
plutôt l'agence américaine donc elle est
elle est très parcellaire et donc en
l'occurrence il y a d'autres études et
si vous contestez la la la solidité
scientifique de l'OMS ou de l'incerms je
pense que le débat va effectivement
commencer à devenir compliqué donc nous
on pense qu'il faut être clair qu'il
faut effectivement changer de modale
agricole mais changer de modale agricole
et ce n'est pas la politique que vous
menez en ce moment en France en tout cas
mais ça ça prend du temps ça prend
beaucoup de temps vous parlez des
cultures vous parlez globalement de modè
Agri changer de modèle agricole c'est
une expression de bureau parisien enfin
je veux dire je sais pas ce que c'est
vers quel modèle agricole on
vaer vous savez de quoi on parle
vraiment là parce parce que c'est la fin
de ce débat donc il faut concl on parle
d'économie là mais pour utiliser du du
glyphosate ça coûte le glyphosate de
mémoire coûte entre 5 et 6 € le litre on
en utilise entre 1 et 3 l hect d'accord
donc si on met la dose maximum c'est 15
L c'est c'est 15 €. 15 € plus le passage
du pulvérisateur qui doit consommer à
peu près 1 L de Gazo à à l'hctare et qui
va faire largement 30 hactares par par
heure donc ça va revenir à allez 20 25 €
maximum de l'hectare le pendant de ça
c'est d'avoir un un un un grand rateau
large voilà qui est tiré par un tracteur
qui lui va faire 6 haectares à l'heure
et pas 20 ou 30 hactares comme un
pulvérisateur et le tracteur de vent va
consommer 6 L hectares d'accord 6 L
hectares donc oui on a un petit surcou
mais quand vous dites la concurrence
desyisso qu vous
ditesp concurrence déloyale par rapport
par rapport aux autres agriculteurs
européens nous on est agriculteur bio on
utilise ça et on vend nos produits et en
plus on les vend de moins en
moinsort mais on s' sort monsur tout
bien pour pouro pourquoi en même temps
on nous explique que le bio est dans
crise et et que que ça se vend pas et
que les agriculteurs bi arrivent plus à
vivre excusez-moi c'est des réponses à
c'est vrai que le marché du bio est est
en crise est en difficulté là le bio va
moins bien parce que effectivement il y
a une inflation et que les gens se la
première chose qui qui dont les gens
enfin dont les consommateurs font c'est
l'économie sur l'alimentaire on est
d'accord mais je suis d'accord avec
Monsieur ça va remonter et puis
voilàir je veux pas rentrer dans la
technique mais c'est bien sur pas toutes
les pas sur toutes les plantes pas sur
tous les types de il y a pas de solution
il y a c'est des solutions violentes et
rapides je pense qu'il faut parler avec
eu faut respecter les agriculteurs
vous faites un métier magnifique et
c'est il faut simplement vous écoutez
vous les bios écouez les autres et puis
et puis essayer de faire évoluer les
choses ça ne se fera pas
rid ai finir avec la tartuferie
écologiste je parle pas pour vous je
parle pour la politique oui oui qui
consiste parce que j'ai trop envie de
direine ce qu'on a fait avec les
bassines de Saint Soline ben regardez un
petit peu circul dans Paris ça vous
arrive de marcher à Paris et vous verrez
tous ces canivaux avec de la flotte ça
peut couler pendant une journée mais des
bassines de
sa vous soutz vous
soutenez
pseudoist à saine et puis vous laissz
l'au couler pendant des journées en dans
les canivaux parisiens
bravo vous aurez encore plein de temps
pour nous faire des des belles sorties
comme ça on s'arrête là merci beaucoup
on a dit plein de choses chacun se fera
son opinion allez vous restez avec moi
France dans une dizaine de minutes on va
retrouver nos affranchis pour leur
partie prix Nathan de ver et son billet
philo qui va se demander s'il existe un
échappatoire à l'affrontement binaire
quand contre quand et puis de quoi nous
parlez-vous ce soir Marco Pomier dans
Bourbon Express chauf qui peut Miriam on
va parler d'une proposition loi sur les
discriminations capillaires à tout à
l'heure les amis vous serez rejoint
d'ailleurs par Yael Goose de France
interre pour son parti prix politique
mais d'abord on va plonger France on y
va dans dans vos 500 pages et bien après
le sursaut après la Belle Époque voici
le tome 3 de votre histoire intime de la
5e République et il est comme toujours
absolument féroce et réjouissant même si
le titre mérite une vraie explication
tragédie française c'est l'histoire d'un
pays qui ne s'aime plus tout simplement
qui n'est plus fier de son histoire la
faute au club des démolisseurs regardez
c'est dans l'invitation de Stéphanie
despierr et on en parle tous les deux
tranquillement et longuement juste
[Musique]
après si on vous invite Fran Olivier
Gisbert c'est parce qu'on ne se lasse
pas de votre regard féroce et de votre
plume serrée pour croquer cette classe
politique française que vous avez
étroitement côtoyé vous êtes
éditorialiste au point journaliste radio
télé et patron vous avez dirigé
plusieurs titres et écrit des
biographies voici donc tragédie
française 3e et dernier volume de votre
histoire intime de la 5e République qui
met le souvenir personnel et confidences
des politiques vous essayez de vous
inscrire dans les pas de château-
brillant dans tragédie française le
récit commence en
1981 vous fustigez ce que vous appelez
les SEP chevaliers du déclin cinq
présidents de la République deux
premierers ministres mitéran Chirac
baladure Jospin Sarkozi Holland Macron
tous coupables selon vous d'avoir laissé
filer les déficits et s'opérer un grand
dérèglement migratoire de François
mitteran vous écrivez s'il n'a pas
changé la vie il a au moins réussi à
plomber l'économie shirac est dites-vous
un roi fait néant un président
malheureux et rendu impotant dès le
départ par les grèves de l'automne
1995 à coup de phrases drôles et
méchantes d'anecdotes consignées dans
carnet vous dénoncez 40 ans de crise de
la volonté politique de Lionel Jospin
vous dites il a abîmé le pays sans le
faire exprès en croyant bien faire vous
confiez vos regrets d'avoir participé à
une campagne anti-Hollande vous osez
réver d'un tandem Sarkozi Hollande qui
aurait allié leur qualité il n'y a
qu'avec Emmanuel Macron que vous n'avez
pas de lien privilégié notamment car dès
sa campagne en 2017 une de ses
déclarations vous fait bondir il n'y a
d'ailleurs pas une culture française il
y a une culture en France elle est
diverse elle est multiple malgré votre
proximité avec ces chefs d'État aucun ne
trouve grâce à vos yeux alors Fran
Olivier Gisbert des SEP chevaliers du
déclin qui a fait le plus de mal au pays
ah je peux répondre à cette question
réponse mais non je peux pas répondre
mais quel est le
principal responsable mais mitan ça
commence avec lui effectivement mit a
beaucoup de qualit mit Teran c'est un
homme d'état vous l'avez admiré
longtemps oui mais toujours toujours
parce qu' l'homme privé était
sensationnel et puis il y avait toute
une partie de miteran vous savez sur la
France la façon de voir la France la
géopolitique tout ça il sentait bien le
problème c'est l'économie il a plombé
complètement et c'est-à-dire que de GA
avit fait un travail formidable 1958 il
remet tout desquer et puis regardez dans
les années 70 la France est un modèle à
l'étranger l'étude de lson Institute
tous ces amerloces qui arrivent ici en
France pour regarder c'est là que se
dessine l'avenir du monde c'est
formidable le modèle français ça c'est
dans les années c'est 1970 et et puis en
80 il y a beaucoup d'argent dans les
caisses et on vide tout et on pense
idioe totale on pense qu'en dépensant
plus on va créer de la croissance bah on
a vu le résultat hein et c'est c'était
c'est l'été l'effondrement voler
d'ailleurs terriblement pour ça mais
vous épargnez votre ami Pierre Morois
hein qui a essayé de limiter la casse je
népargne pas pierre Moroi non non pierre
Moroi il a résisté il s'est battu il
aimait miteran parce que miteran c'est
quelqu'un qu'on pouvait aimer donc il
était très loyal mais en privé avec
mitéran avec ses conseillers il était
extrêmement violent et il a fait la
rigueur le célèbre tournant de la
rigueur c'est lui seul qui l'a imposé
d'ailleurs en à un moment donné après
les les municipales de 1983 il a dit
toute façon ben je m'en vais moi je vais
pas faire cette politique idiote on va
pas continuer comme ça et finalement
mitan l'a écouté alors erreur
fondamentale de la gauche vous en parlez
longuement sur l'économie déni aussi de
cette gauche sur la question migratoire
vous parlez même d'un terrorisme
intellectuel de la gauche dans cette
scène incroyable he où jeandiiel patron
du Nouvel Observateur se fait très
clairement remettre à sa place par
François miteron oui qui lui dit à un
moment donné vous parlez comme Le Pen
parce que évidemment Jeandel dit mais
attendez ça va poser un problème enfin
c'estàdire il y a ce déni qui est très
très fort très violent moi-même je je
vois bien dans dans cette époque là je
on vous tombe dessus quand vous en
parlez chance qu'on avait pas le droit
de dire non non mais c'est vrai que ça
commence cette espèce de chape de plomb
qui va tomber mais sur l'économie aussi
il fallait jamais critiquer je me
souviens qu'est-ce que j'ai pas entendu
pendant quand Jospin a fait cette enfin
Jospin c'est surtout au BRI d'ailleurs
cette absurde réduction du temps de
travail qui devait créer des emplois pas
un seul emploi rien il y a pas eu un
seul emploi de créer et on on et vous
savez les Français sont beaucoup moins
cons que les politiques que les
politiques de l'époque qui ont fait ça
ils sont beaucoup moins bêtes parce que
les Français vous faites tous les
sondages sur la même chose les Français
disent très très mauvaise mesure
économique mais on veut pas changer
surtout on change pas parce
qu'évidemment bah oui on en profite tous
ça c'est vrai c cette C cité de la
gauche vous en parlez aussi sur sur la
question de la montée de l'islamisme que
vous situez dans les années 90 avec les
années de plomb d'ailleurs en Algérie
d'ailleurs vous aussi vous dites j'ai
pas compris ah oui il y a beaucoup de
choses que j'ai ah non mais croire que
la République ne permettrait pas
d'absorber tout ça moi j'ai toujours cru
que tout ça se passerait assez bien
après c'est vrai que les flot
migratoires l'idée de pas contrôler les
flot migratoires parce que c'est un peu
comme ça avec tous les clandestins et
cetera tout ça ça commence dans les
années 80 90 c'est dément ça je le
trouve en même temps je me dis
mais la machine va absorber tout ça mais
aussi parce que je suis très républicain
et je suis partisan de la laïcité vous
savez moi je suis fils de prof ma mère
prof de philo mais mais c'était à qui
vous rendez un très bel homage
d'ailleurs oui mais ma mère était mais
c'était dingue c'està-dire la religion
n'avait pas le droit de rentrer elle
était C navait pas le droit de rentrer
dans le lycée pétait les plombs la
politique non plus elle était militant
de politique recardienne enfin elle
militait beaucoup et la politique pas de
politique ça c'est une un autre temps et
si vous voulez ce temps-là alors on
voyait bien tout ça commençait à être
sapé et c'est moi c'est vrai que je
croyais aussi que ça pouvait peut-être
marcher mais en même temps je voulais
fendre cette république elle commençait
à chanceler et là c'est vrai qu'c le
dernier président on est rentré dans un
truc qui ressemble un peu au
communautarisme mais mais mais regardez
présid ce passe aujourd'hui c'est très
intéressant parce que aujourd'hui on
voit quand on voit ce qui se passe en
Grande-Bretagne on voit très bien que le
modèle républicain qui est très attaqué
y compris par beaucoup de macronistes le
modèle républicain c'est quand même 100
fois mieux que le modèle communautariste
on n pas des foules énormes qui se
candent mort aux Juifs comme ça dans les
dans les rues de Paris c'est qu même
c'est mieou voilà voilà ça va pas bien
du tout en France mais quand on se
compit Jacques Chirac dont vous adoriez
la compagnie vous l'avez écrit sur de
nombreuses pages sympathique aussi
sympathique que lâche écrivez-vous il
vous confie après l'abandon de la
réforme des régimes spéciaux en 1995 la
France n'a plus je cite qu'une ambition
rester planté jusqu'à la nuit des temps
à écouter l'herbe poussée lui non plus
n'a fait n'a fait preuve d'aucun courage
politique ah non était capable de
courage politique non non non non non
non sur l'international sur l'Irak ça
c'est lui on a fait croire que c'était
Villepin mais c'est lui moi j'ai des
conversations d'ailleurs je cite ces
phrases mais était d'une violence
absolument incroyable et il voyait bien
parce qu'il sentait très bien lui son
grand problème c'était l'islamisme on
peut pas dire qu'il avait pas vu le truc
venir c'est pour ça qu'il défendait tous
les régimes d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
qu'il défendait Saddam Hussein c'est
pour ça qu'il défendait Ben Ali même
s'il a pas trop défendu sur la fin c'est
pour ça qu'il était très copain aussi
avec Mbarak en pour lui il préférait
dictature ou le régime dur parce qu'il
disait attention le vrai danger c'est
l'islamisme et il disait cette guerre
bon et puis sur plein d'autres sujets
regardez sur l'histoire du veldive je
peux ENF il y a 50 discours de Chirac où
on voit quand même brusquement il se
réveill mais encore l'économomie est
toujours l'économie c'est ça alors
l'économie l'économie c'est compliqué
Chirac c'est qu'à un moment donné
effectivement il y a une forme d'abandon
on peut pas y arriver avec ses français
voyez avec je l'entend parler si vous
voulez quand j'entends Chirac et que je
relis les phrases de De Gaulle il y a un
peu de ça ouis on peut rien faire avec
ces gens-l c'est les Français c'est pas
Mo oui oui non non céit oui le côté
comment dire vantard voyez que un peu
lâche tout ce qu'on lit dans la Guer
d'IG de César voyez que on avance avance
vous avez cette formule que j'ai trouvé
géniale jusqu'à Sarkozy la droite n'est
qu'une gauche qui aime les agriculteurs
et la police c'est vrai Nicolas Sarkozi
va changer ça ou il essaye il essaye
vous avez toujours autant de haine
contre lui moins qu'avant c'estàd que
c'està-dire que Nicolas Sarkozi j'avoue
j'étais très violent pendant son son
cacana et quand on prend un peu de recul
moi c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
j'essaie d'être honnête je suis avec
j'ai mes malles pleines de de dossiers
de de notes que j'avais prises de de
journal même une époque c'est
extraordinaire je te dis mon journal
donc tout ça et je vois très bien
j'avais trop de passion et en fait il a
essayé bon il a été bloqué dans plein
d'endroits mais enfin il a quand même
fait quelques chose quelques petites
choses disons ou vous le reconnaissez
quand on se souvient la dendure que vous
aviez contre lui vous avait quelques
pages pour dire au moins en temps de
crise il était il était là il était très
bon il faut dire sur la crise financière
primes bon il a beaucoup endetter la
France à cette occasion mais quand
même il a évité des catastropes surtout
il a mené non non puis il a mené la
stratégie internationale ENF on voit
très bien regarder sur l'Europe parce
qu'en fait on a tout de suite été
impacté par cette crise tout de suite on
ne sait pas d'ailleurs c'est en
travaillant sur C je meen suis rendu
compte l'histoire de tout de suite qui
est arrivé avec la BNP c'était un truc
c'était c'était nous quoi ouais et il a
réussi ça notamment avec avec Angela
Merkel François Hollande pour qui vous
aviez de l'estime au départ vous déçois
profondément il y a cette scène qui est
à peine croyable hein franchement il
faut la lire et la relire on s'est dit
c'est pas possible plein de témoin euh
vous lui pr vous lui prédisez devant
témoins la fin de son quinquena ta
présidence est foutue alors que tu crois
qu'elle vient de commencer raconte-nous
oui en face une scène c'était à l'Élysée
une remise de de prix et cetera et je
voyais pendant le comme j'étais dans le
jury j'étais là tout près je voyais
qu'il me regardais tout le temps je suis
dit merde on je je sais affronter les
choses effectivement dès que le truc est
terminé il fonde sur moi et il gueule
enfin parce que ou parce qu'il était
très très énervé contre vos unes avec la
montre à l'envers nit j'avais fait qui
était horrible des photos qui étaient
pas sympa des titres qui étaient alors
on se réveille alors on continue avec
les bêtises enfin voyez ce genre de truc
très violent quoi et et et c'est le
point qui avait commencé d'ailleurs
alors que après la presse a suivi parce
qu'il voyait que ça marchait très bien
mais moi j'étais assez énervé parce que
mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait voyez il
arrive au pouvoir et il fait rien or on
sait très bien que la si on veut changer
un pays il faut le faire dans les 100
premiers jours et et donc il commence à
me gueuler dessus et je réponds mais oui
effectivement je ce que vous avez dit
c'est-à-dire oui mais qui vous répond
finalement la main sur l'épaule jeis
vous dire et c'est là qu'on voit c'est
il est très intelligent non non mais il
est très intelligent je souviens Olivier
d'asso qui était tout près qui était là
il y avait pas mal de chefs d'entreprise
m' dit mais ce type il est quand même il
était fasciné disait par l'intelligence
aussi c'est-à-dire que il met la main
sur l'épaule il me dit je crains que tu
n'es raison je crains que tu n'aes
raison il nous reste une Poé de secondes
on va passer sur Emmanuel Macron
d'ailleurs il vous intéresse qu'à
moitier vous dites qu'il est narcissique
qu'il se suffit à lui-même vous l'avez
pas vraiment cherché à le à le
rencontrerimais mon parce que tout n'est
pas foutu c'est ça qui est
intéressant vous avez quand même un tout
petit peu de d'optimisme pour un sursaut
je vais vous montrer quatre on en a
chois qu pas mourir elle est tellement
belle non la beauté ne meurt jamais on a
choisi après réflexion avec mon équipe
quatre personnalités qui peuvent avoir
un destin à venir on verra qui sur ces
quatre là Édouard Philippe Bernard
casneuve Éric Zemour François Ruffin a
le bon diagnostic sur le pays selon vous
je pense que d'abord Édouard Philippe
c'est le candidat des des journalistes
des médias et des patrons du patronat
oui pas le vôtre euh bah non forcément
ils sont toujours plantés ceuxlà ça
marche pas hein en général c'est
regardez dans le passé c'est BG B la du
et cetera oubliez Éric Zemour moi je lui
ai dit bah il est pas fait pour faire la
politique c'est un chroniqueur bon benah
il a voulu changer de métier en plus
faut jamais changer de métier trop tard
il aurait dû commencer à 30 ans voyz
rhabiller pour l'IV
euh casen il est sur un bon créneau
c'est quelqu'un tout à fait intelligent
de remarquable je dirais c'est une
personnalité remarquable mais ça prend
pas et pourquoi ça prend pas parce que
je pense qu'il fait pas les efforts bah
il faut qu'il fasse faut faut qu'il
fasse un peu les trateaux coco donc
çaér alors lui il est intéressant mais
euh il faut faire il a affaire à très
forte partie parce que Mélenchon que
encore la presse mort mais non mais
délenchon il est pas mort Mélenchon
n'est pas mort du tout mélenchant il a
une stratégie 15 % je veux le votre
musulman et cetera j'agglomère des trucs
autour et à partir de 15 % je suis très
fort donc le la la succession de
Mélenchon bah ça peut être qu'une
histoire de santé à un moment donné mais
je veux dire je je pense qu'il est
encore là puis qu'il souhaite se
présenter la prochaine présidentielle
mais bon il peut attendre c'est dit
tragédie française au singulier personne
n'a vraiment grâce aux yeux de de France
mais pas complètement parce que vous
êtes tendre
c'est Ro et même certains certain moment
Chirac regardez Chirac en 86 et 88 il a
été B il faut s'arrêter sinon vous
n'urez plus le temps de réagir à il y en
a plein d'autres il y en a plein
d'autres allez c'est àdire chez galimar
ça cartonne déjà même sans promo monori
regardez
ça non mais attendezah oui mais je
remonte ça ça fait rêver bah je vais
vous dire non non non il faut s'arrêter
sacré bonhomme he garagiste d'accord
mais il savait compter allez on s'arrête
là vous allez pouvoir réagir à présent à
nos parties prix nos affranchis on les
accueille tout de
suite allez y ELG va falloir faire vite
si vous voulez laisser réagir parce
qu'il est prolix y elgos de France
interre le
billet le billet politique bien sûr et
le billet philo avec Nathan de ver
installez-vous on va commencer par
Bourbon express chaque soir une histoire
à l'Assemblée nationale qui a marqué
l'actu du jour Marco Pomier bonsoir
c'est vous qui nous la racontez ce soir
bonsoir Miriam ce soir je vous raconte
une histoire capillaire alors pas
question de parler de franges de dégradé
ou même de perruque d'abord je suis pas
spécialiste et puis ça serait un peu tié
par les cheveux sur LCP non ce soir je
vous parle des injustices capillaires
c'est le combat d'Olivier serva déput
éliotte de Guadeloupe il veut en finir
avec les discriminations liées à la
texture la longueur la couleur ou la la
coupe de cheveux c'est très sérieuxiam
il porte une proposition loi sur le
sujet ça me parle écout forcément
fondamental c'est faut faire vite ça oui
bien sû Olivier serva soutenu donc par
une cinquantaine de députés de la gauche
au Républicain en passant par la
majorité et il organise en ce moment
même à l'Assemblée un colloque sur la
question écoutez ce témoignage faire en
ce moment c'est bien ça vous vous avez
été discriminé pour vos cheveux
exactement ça m'est arrivé à plusieurs
choses que ce soit à l'école au travail
également ça m'est arrivé qu'on m refusé
de venir avec mon cheveux détaché qu'il
fallait l'attacher puisque c'était pas
professionnel ou alors on m'a dit de
venir la prochaine fois avec un
entretien d'embauche les cheveux
attachés ou lysées puisque soi-disant
mon cheveux est considéré comme sauvage
sale négligé j'ai l'impression qu'on me
demandait de changer mon identité ou mon
ADN bon CLA Miriam sont visé les femmes
afro les les blondes les chauves aussi
le point de départ du combat d'Olivier
serva et bien c'est la condamnation
d'Air France après 10 ans de bataille
juridique la compagnie aérienne avait
interdit le port de tresse afro à l'un
de ces Steewart bon alors il y a des
exemples est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
mesurer l'ampleur de ces de ces
discrimination et ben on peut au moins
s'appuyer sur des études menées au
Royaume-Uni et aux États-Unis 2 tiers
des femmes noires américaines disent
changer de coupe de cheveux avant un
entretien d'embauche près de la moitié
se sent obligés de les lisser sinon vous
êtes perçu comme moins professionnel par
les employeurs plus inquiétant encore
les femmes qui utilisent des produits
pour se défriser les cheveux auraient
trois fois plus de risque de développer
des cancers de l'utérus et puis chers
messieurs si vous n'avez plus
grand-chose sur le caillou et bien
sachez que vous avez moins de chance
d'obtenir des entretiens d'embauche bref
Myriam pour Olivier serva et bien c'est
bien la preuve qu'il y a un problème
universel
sociologiquement devoir s'aplatir les
cheveux c'est aplatir sa personnalité
s'aplatir soi-même et donc ne pas être
bien pour la société quand on n'est pas
bien pour la société ça n'est pas bon
pour le bien vivre ensemble la loi elle
permet déjà aujourd'hui de punir les
discrimin nation pour apparence physique
oui ça c'est le principe mais la réalité
est tout autre j'ai identifié un trou
dans la raquette législative et
indéiablement quand je vous regarde je
regarde votre visage et ce que vous avez
au-dessus du visage ça se voit plus
queautre chose et donc ce trou d'un
raquette nous demande de mettre un focus
particulier sur cette discrimination
évidente bon Olivier serva espère un
consensus he sur la question feu vert en
tout cas du côté de la Présidence de
l'Assemblée reste à inscrire la
proposition de loi à l'agenda lors d'une
semaine dédié aux propositions des
députés en janvier prochain espère
Olivier serva d'un mot bon ça fait
plaisir c'est un moment pour rire hein
dans dans une période un peu difficile
parce que c'est une séquence comique
mais j'ai beaucoup ri vive les bouclés
je dis et les frisés comme moi on
enchaîne avec vous tout le est une
victime il a El Go je je m attendais
Chau et ce qu' trop de cheveux bon on
enchaîne avec vous vous voulez nous
parler de ces rencontres en format
Saint-Denis c'est le c'est le nom
désormais de d'Emmanuel Macron il y en a
une demain trois chefs de parti ont
décliné l'invitation tion et le
président depuis la suite a été
extrêmement dur hein il parle même de de
faute politique majeur les absents
ont-il vraiment tort pour la France
insoumise on va dire qu'on n pas surpris
parce que c'est la conflictualisation
permanente ils sont antisystème donc la
couleur avaitté annoncé depuis plusieurs
jours là on est plus surpris c'est voir
deux leaders de deux anciens partis de
gouvernement socialistes et républicains
rxioti Olivier fort qui vont sécher ce
rendez-vous là ça interroge davantage
parce que les deux chaises vides les
leurs vont laisser symboliquement encore
plus de place à qui au RN à Jordane
Bardella qui sera là et qui pourra lui
se targuer d'être la première opposition
présente responsable à Emmanuel Macron
ça c'est l'incohérence sur la forme et
sur le fond B ils ont tort aussi selon
moi car en quoi l'ordre du jour fixé par
le président serait incompatible avec
leur formation politique il s'agit de
faire un point sur la
situation entre Israël et le Hamas sur
notre action diplomatique sur nos otages
et surtout d'évoquer un grand grand
sujet l'élargissement du référendum
alors article 11 ça ça parle vraiment
républicain il porte ce sujet et le rip
référendum l'initiative partagé qu'on
pourrait simplifier ça c'est une réforme
poussée par les socialistes B ils seront
pas là ils ont même tort myiam une
troisième fois parce qu'ils sont venus
déjà la dernière fois il y a pas de
cohérence notamment au sein de la nupes
puisque vous aurez l'écologiste marine
Tondelier et le communiste Fabien
Roussel à la table et puis je sais pas
si vous avez vu Olivier fort il fait des
propositions intéressantes dans un
nouveau livre sur les inégalités de
patrimoine en France bah ça c'est
l'occasion dire les choses d'exposer
d'aller face au président dire des
choses marine Tondelier vient pour
parler climat alors que c'est pas
l'ordre du jour mais elle vient avec son
thème alors donc si on vous suit le
président peut légitimement se poser en
en victime de leur sectarisme antithèse
le problème c'est que depuis 2018 et les
gilets jaunes le président Emmanuel
Macron brille dans le concours l'épine
de l'innovation démocratique permanente
grand débat national Cahet de doléance
convention citoyenne climat fin de vie
Conseil national de la refondation et
maintenant le format séminaire pour quel
résultat à chaque fois combien de fois
il y a eu un filtre finalement du
président ou alors classé sans suite où
sont les cahiers de doléance où est le
projet de loi fin de vie y a-t-il eu un
scénaire sur les retraites non donc la
confiance elle peut pas être totale
cette manière d'associer pour retrouver
du consensus pourquoi pas mais ça signe
aussi et surtout en ce moment sa
difficulté à major à gouverner sans
majorité absolue en oubliant au passage
que c'est au Parlement que tout ça est
censé se passer et se débattre pas entre
chef de parti ce boycotte de main met en
lumière la solitude croissante
d'Emmanuel Macron sa perte d'influence
condamné à ne pas pouvoir rempiler mais
c'est pas une raison pour dès maintenant
dès 2023 refuser leséchanges la
discussion sans savoir à l'avance si les
dés sont pipés ou si au contraire tout
ça peut déboucher un peu sur du commun
he il y en a pas beaucoup en ce moment
dans les jeux politiciens d'accord avec
l'analyse j'aime beaucoup il Goose mais
là je suis pas d'accord avec lui parce
que non non parce que je suis pas
d'accord sur la chute et puis je suis
pas d'accord non plus sur le début
pourquoi parce que d'habitude enfin
c'est vrai qu' il y a une bonne façon de
pas se tromper trop j'ai remarqué en
politique c'est de dire un peu le
contraire des journalistes des médias
regardez ils disent grosse erreur de
siti mais je trouve pour une fois enfin
pas peut-être pas pour une fois mais
c'est très malin c'est-à-dire que il
laisse Macron seul face à bardala et il
y a vous qui croyez que c'est un truc
sérieux c'est de la con cette histoire
de de c'est totalement Bidz
découvrir moi je pense qu'ils doivent
travailler ensemble se voir souvent
c'est le président de la République doit
recevoir comme ses prédécesseurs il doit
recevoir souvent les chefs de parties d
qu'il le peut à chaque occasion ce truc
c'est un grand barnome pour faire des
images à la télé c'est de
la comme ça tue la politique vous
vouliez nous parler ce soir d'un mot qui
vous a interpellé je sais pas si je vais
y arriver la notion de what abouttisme
oui déjà il faut le prononcertism
watoutisme je ne sais pas comment j'ai
découvert C anglicisme cette semaine à
la faveur d'un débat public qui tend de
plus en plus à se crisper comme ça et à
devenir une sorte d'affrontement binaire
un antagonisme entre deux camps qui
refusent de s'écouter que ce soit sur le
conflit israëlo-palestinien sur les
retraites sur l'Ukraine demain sur je ne
sais quel sujet et donc j'ai vu que sur
les réseaux sociaux cette tendance
commenca à naître d'avec deux camps qui
s'accusent mutuellement très souvent de
faire du wataboutisme je vais le dire à
la française parce que j'ai un mauvais
accent anglais donc je l'assume alors
qu'est-ce que c'est le wataboutisme
exemple concret imaginez que je vienne
demain dire à un de mes amis qu'il a
tort de fumer parce que c'est mauvais
pour sa santé et qui me répondent que je
suis très mal placé pour lui dire ça
parce que je suis moi-même un grand
fumeur ce serait du wataboutisme total
exemple politique c'est quand si vous
voulez quand quelqu'un fait une
réfutation ou une objection qu'on vient
attirer l'attention sur le fait qu'il
est mal placé pour donner cette
objection conflit israë au Palestiniens
c'est par exemple de dire le 7 octobre a
été une horreur oui mais regardez à Gaza
les civils meurent aussi autre exemple
de wataboutisme politique très
intéressant dans la rhtorique de
Vladimir Poutine je ne respecte pas les
droits de l'homme mais l'Occident a
lui-même sous soutenu la guerre en Irak
et donc il est très mal placé pour me
donner cette c'est vrai que
effectivement c'est très très présent
dans le débat public je confirme j'ai
j'ai en permanence moi sur ce plateau
alors est-ce que il est seulement
possible d'échapper à ce wataboutisme
oui il me semble que ce wataboutisme cet
art de renvoyer la balle cet art de la
rhétorique de la discussion en boomerang
en fait il naît d'une conception
béliqueuse du débat et d'une sorte
d'allergie à la réfutation ça veut dire
que la réfutation est perçue comme une
attaque exactement comme dans un combat
de boxe une attaque qui s'agit
absolument de renvoyer d'éviter de et
comme si c'était la grande menace du
débat alors c'est ce qu'on appelait dans
la Grèce antique léristique la croyance
que la rhétorique est un combat contre
cela il y a une autre vision qui est
notamment la vision du dialogue du débat
philosophique que Socrate promeut
notamment dans un texte très important
qui est le Gorgias ou affrontant les
grands maîtres de la rhétorique grecque
il dit je le cite littéralement veux-tu
savoir quel quel type d'homme je suis je
suis quelqu'un qui estime qu'il y a plus
grand avantage à être réfuté que de
réfuter dans la mesure où se débarrasser
du pire des mots fait plus de bien qu'en
délivré autrui magnifique on va on va
méditer on va méditer Socrate merci
beaucoup je vous propose de répondre à
Nathan en dehors de ce studio parce que
le temps qui nous est imparti s'achève
maintenant tragédie française c'est le
trème t il y en aura un
autre pense peut-être oui oui il y aura
peut-être une suite à un moment donné
mais bon oui oui ouiire intime de la 5
République j'ai plein de chutes vous
savez come on dit j'ai plein de plein de
choses
encore parce que ce pays est magnifique
et on est ça n'est pas fini la France
n'est jamais fini jamais fini ça on sera
d'accord jamais fini ça va très mal ça
c'est sûr on est pe fond au fond du fond
vous entendez la petite musique on va
revenir c'est fini on se quitte
là-dessus très belle soirée sur LCP
soirée documentaire avec Jean-Pierre
Gratien à demain merci de votre
[Musique]
fidélité